Major breaking news as a federal
district court judge in Texas has just
upheld a series of quote unquote
sensitive places laws which as you know
is a euphemism for governmentmandated
gun-free zones dealing with racetracks
basically sporting events and guess what
bars. This was a wrongly decided
decision by a otherwise generally good
judge. We're going to break down how he
can improve in the future and get the
sensitive place issue right.
Hey folks, I'm Mark Smith, host of the
four box of donor, proud American gun
owner, constitutional attorney, member
of the United States Supreme Court Bar
and I'm proud to say the top voice of
the Second Amendment in America. Thank
you. Both 2025 and 2026 Gundies awards.
All right, folks. So, we have a major
decision out there in federal district
court in Texas. Uh the case is Zanfice
or Zeanfuss versus Martin. I hope I got
Mr. Zean Fuss's name correctly,
pronounced it correctly. Against Martin.
This was a case, a lawsuit challenging
various Texas laws that prohibited the
carrying of guns in certain places,
specifically bringing guns into types of
bars, uh, where they serve more than 51%
of the businesses basically
alcohol-driven. That seems like a bar to
me. Uh, also to kind of sporting events,
intercolastic events at all levels from
professional down to the amateur and
also at racetracks. And unfortunately,
Judge Mark Pitman, who is usually a very
good judge, appointed to the bench by
Donald Trump, does a very good job. He
actually clearly worked really hard on
this decision. He he tried to get it
right, but unfortunately, he got it
wrong. He made a lot of sort of errors,
and we're going to go through those now
about how to improve that moving forward
and get it right when this case goes to
the United States Court of Appeals for
the Fifth Circuit down there in
Louisiana, Mississippi, and Texas. Okay.
So to begin with again the three laws
that were being challenged are as
follows. Texas law makes it a crime to
carry firearms in a number of public
spaces. Texas law prohibits
intentionally knowingly or recklessly
possessing or going with a firearm
location restricted knife club or
prohibited weapon on the premises of
three types of spaces. First, this
provision applies to racetracks. Second,
this provision applies to premises of a
business that has a permit or license
issued under the relevant law. if the
business deres 51% or more of its income
from the sale or service of alcoholic
beverages for on premises consumption.
And third, the prohibition applies to
premises where a high school collegiate
or professional sporting event or
interscolastic event is taking place.
Texas has enjoyed the protection
keyword. Texas has enjoyed the
protection of these laws passed by their
elected representatives for decades,
citing back to 1973
when dinosaurs walked the earth
apparently. Okay, so those are the laws
being challenged. Obviously, Judge
Pitman is off on the wrong track right
off the bat. So, he indicates that these
laws protected Texans, right, under the
protection of these laws. We know that's
hoie because not only do gun-free zones
not protect people, they actually
encourage violence. Which is why, as
Professor John L has demonstrated over
and over and over again, and we can just
see with our own eyes.
Every time you see another mass
shooting, it's at a gun-free zone. So to
start off on page one of an opinion
saying that Texas has received the
BENEFIT OF THE PROTECTIONS of these laws
that are gun-free zones means you know
you're going down the wrong path right
off the bat. When Judge Pitman came out
and said that these modern laws in those
places are consistent with the
long-standing history of firearms
regulation in America going back to the
founding. Not true. Not even close to
being true to begin with. He he does say
kind of the right things. He says that
the Supreme Court really does focus on
1791 and the founding era. And that's
something I've been pushing hard with my
article in the Harvard Journal of Law
and Public Policy that's been cited like
I don't know hundreds of times in all
these cases. And rightly so because I'm
articulating correctly what the Supreme
Court thinks and what the Supreme Court
will ultimately say unequivocally.
They've already basically done it. The
1791 is the key time period. And here's
the key problem with this opinion as to
what Judge Pitman does. He sort of
equivocates. He kind of says he says the
right things that 1791 is really the key
time period and that late 19th century
reconstruction era laws might be
relevant. And the re remember the reason
why it might be relevant as a
conceivable thing is that in 1868 after
the civil war the 14th amendment was
adopted to protect the freed
African-American slaves. So there are
some scholars that argue that the proper
time period for determining what was
understood as to the meaning of the
second amendment is actually in 1868
when the 14th amendment was adopted and
applied effectively the bill of rights
to the states. But that's not correct
because 1791 is when you look for the
substantive meaning of the bill of
rights. The substantive meaning of the
first amendment right to free speech,
the substantive meaning of the right to
bear arms. All that is said in 1791. The
only change that occurs in the year of
our lord 1868 after the civil war is you
expanded who benefits from those rights
from 1791 i.e. the freed
African-American slaves benefit from the
bill of rights. Now that's what the 14th
amendment was about. And at the same
time, the 14th amendment also took the
bill of rights and expanded to whom it
restricted. And remember, the bill of
rights in 1791 only restricted the
powers and the ability of the federal
government to act. When you enact the
14th amendment, you not only protect the
African-American slaves, the former
slaves, you also ex restrict the ability
of states and localities, state and
local governments to act as well. That's
all the 14th amendment did. Now with
that said to step back just briefly the
proper way to discuss the relationship
between looking at historical laws
involving firearms in 1791 versus 1868
is as follows. This is how you square
the circles. And Judge Pitman did not
get this right. He did not articulate
this correctly. I don't know if he fully
appreciated this, but I'm going to
clarify it right here and right now.
1791 is when you define the scope of the
Second Amendment. You likewise use
historical analog laws involving
firearms to the extent they exist in
1791 and that time period of the
founding era.
It is true that late 19th century 1868
firearms laws and other activities could
be relevant to your issue
but they can only be relevant in a
single particular way. Late late 19th
century 1868 related laws dealing with
firearms can be relevant to the extent
they are confirmatory analytics. Which
means that what happened in 1868
confirms the 1791 understanding in the
sense that whatever was going on in the
late 19th century was the same sort of
things going on in the 18th century. In
other words, it's confirming what was
already going on. What cannot happen,
which Judge Pitman did here erroneously,
even though he kind of indicates he
didn't, but he did, was he embraced 19th
century laws
despite the fact there's no 1791 laws to
connect the dots, right? He talks about
these laws involving uh guns and taverns
and all this stuff in the late 19th
century and all this other stuff. But
again, there is no hook back to 1791,
which means the late 19th century laws
he relies upon here to uphold these
Texas laws had no anchor in 1791 to the
founding era. And therefore, the late
19th century laws were not confirming
the historical tradition of firearms
regulation from 1791 because there was
no historical tradition of firearms
regulation involving these kinds of
issues in 1791. So, you can't use the
19th century laws as a confirmatory
analytic because there's nothing for
them to confirm because you cannot
confirm nothing if that makes sense.
Now, the next big mistake Judge Pitman
makes here is she doesn't even really
define what a sensitive place is. And
again, we've talked about what a
sensitive place is. If you look at the
three things in Bruin that the Supreme
Court says are clearly sensitive places
in their view, courouses, legislative
chambers, and polling places at the time
of the founding, not polling places
today, polling places at the time of the
founding when there was an open vote and
everyone knew how you voted unlike today
where we moved to the Australian ballot
system in the late 19th century. So,
it's different today. That's why you
don't see security at polling places so
much today, but at the time of the
founding, you did because you had to
announce that you supported George
Washington publicly and people could get
mad at you because they found out what
you thought. But again, you go back to
the founding era. What brought what was
the common denominator, the common theme
that showed that polling places in the
18th century, the courouses in the 18th
century, the legislative chambers in the
18th century, the three places that
Brewan said were sensitive places,
meaning you could ban guns there, they
all had government provided security.
There were baiffs, there were sheriffs,
there were sheriff deputies, there were
sergeant-at-arms. There were people
there on behalf of the government who
had arms that were protecting these
proceedings. It's all about
comprehensive security. You have to look
at the how and the why of the analoges.
Why something could be sensitive. There
could be a bunch of reasons why a place
might be sensitive, but the how is the
key here. And the how the government
made these places sensitive in the 18th
century was with enhanced government
security. The sort of thing we see at
TSA, the sort of thing when you go into
a federal courthouse, that's
comprehensive security. If you
government does not provide that, it's
not a sensitive place. Don't take my
word for it. Look at the historical
history in the 18th century by scholars
like Dr. Angus Mlelen who published that
powerful piece on SSRN that's gotten a
lot of attention for example. This is
the right answer. Did Judge Pitman do
any of this analyze any of this? No, he
didn't. Not good. Okay. People make
mistakes. People get it happens all the
time. I make mistakes. Okay. It happens.
Okay. Now, with that said, he then goes
on to just declare that schools are
sensitive places. But then he goes on to
admit, this is the weird part. He then
goes on to admit the historical truth
that students were barred from having
guns and having weapons in the 18th
century, BUT NON- STUDENTENTS WERE NOT.
And yet somehow he uses that as a basis
for a lot of his conclusions that, well,
yeah, I know schools are a sensitive
place, even though some people can have
guns and others cannot. No, if people
can have guns there, if the bad guy can
sneak in with the guns, it's not a
sensitive place because you have to
prevent to for it to be sensitive. Not
only do you have to provide armed
security, you also have to make sure bad
people cannot bring guns in. If you
don't do that, then my right to keep and
bear arms, my right to carry guns in
case of confrontation does not get lost
because if you're letting people sneak
in behind the guards with guns
potentially, I need the ability to
defend myself. This is basic common
sense and I think it's entirely
consistent with 18th century history.
Okay. So the next thing he talks about
is the statue of Northampton and he
doesn't quite get this right again. So
basically he talks about how you have a
1328 English statute. 1328 1328 English
statute and he says well you couldn't
bring guns in front of the king or his
men. Again that speaks to government and
comprehensive security because the kings
of course never went anywhere without
security and armed people. But beyond
that, the real understanding of of of
the Statue of Northampton, as the
Supreme Court has said in Bruin, is the
Statue of Northampton is really about
you cannot bring guns to the terror of
the people. Meaning, you cannot bring
guns in a way that misuses them or
scares people. If you're simply
peaceibly carrying arms, that's okie
dokie. But you cannot do it in sort of a
form of terrorism. That's not allowed.
But again, any of these references, you
know, to the king, you can't go armed in
front of the king. Well, again, we know
the king has arms and security, which
goes back to the notion of armed
security. If there's armed security,
then it's possible it could be a
sensitive place. Maybe that's not
enough. But in a minimum, if you do not
have armed security, metal detectors,
limited points of entry, guess what? It
ain't a sensitive place consistent with
the Second Amendment. and I do not lose
my ability to protect myself with
firearms under the Second Amendment,
which again, the right to bear arms
means I have the right to carry guns in
public in case of a potential
confrontation where I need to use those
arms to defend myself, my community, my
family, whatever. Now, the next mistake
that's made in this opinion is he relies
upon a Virginia statute that says that
you could not have guns while there was
basically drinking parties. Now, this is
just the state of Virginia uh from the
year of our Lord 1656. So let's assume
that is an analog law. That's only one
law. That is certainly not enough to
create a historical tradition. Because
if you look at Breuan, uh guess what?
They specifically said that three laws
at the time of the founding were not
enough to create a tradition. So if you
only have three states that have a
particular law, that doesn't create a
historical tradition. Those are
basically outliers. So here he relies
upon a six uh 17th century Virginia
statute. And then having done so, which
is simply not adequate, he then tries to
tie it in and argue that late 19th
century laws confirm that 1600 Virginia
statute. But again, he doesn't establish
the long-standing tradition before he
jumps to the late 19th century, which is
too late. And that's why he says on page
15 specifically that 19th century state
and territorial laws further confirm and
cement these traditions. But again, you
don't use territorial laws because
territorial laws basically had no laws.
They weren't even part of the United
States yet. The Constitution didn't
apply to them. And it wasn't like they
had the ACLU out there litigating
constitutional issues. So, you can't
really ter use territorial laws as any
sort of evidence of a historical
tradition of firearms restrictions cuz
again, they weren't even part of the
country at the time. They were
territories. So, with that said, on page
10, uh this is a terrible mistake. I
probably need to do a video on this cuz
this some people, this is a super nerdy
concept, but it's kind of dangerous. And
that is he uses the doctrine of
liquidation to liquidate your
liquidation because it grabs a language
out of something that James Madison
wrote about how you can liquidate
constitutional provisions. And here's
what he writes. Check it out. With that
said, 1791 is not the exclusive point of
historical analysis because the period
closer to 1868 still plays an important
role in the analysis. Reconstruction
error evidence can help to liquidate to
liquidate a meaning and settle
indeterminacies. wrong. 100% wrong. 100%
terrible. Okay. The doctrine of
liquidation
is a notion that when the United States
Constitution was created, it was a brand
new document. It was a brand new thing,
right? That's what it was. Madison wrote
this Constitution and tried to cobble
together something he thought would
work. It was an invention. It was new.
Now parts of the constitution like the
separation of powers, the scope of
article three of the of the supreme
court, inferior, all this stuff was
brand new. The notion was that after the
constitution was created in the late
18th century for the first many decades,
there was a process of liquidating the
meaning, meaning sort of understanding
what this meant over time. and you look
at the practices of the founders to
liquidate the meeting of provisions of
the constitution. Okay? But here's the
key distinction. Listen carefully,
folks.
The doctrine of liquidation cannot and
should not ever be applied in Second
Amendment juristprudence because it will
screw up the Second Amendment. It is
simply objectively wrong. And if you
support the second amendment, you should
not argue for liquidation in the context
of second amendment jurist prudence.
Why? Because the second amendment did
what? It cautified a preexisting set of
rights.
It was not dealing with a brand new
issue. The second amendment did not
create something new. It codified
pre-existing historical rights going
back to the rights of the Englishmen. So
the analysis when you're applying the
second amendment is not to look for
liquidating the meaning of the second
amendment is to look at history as to
what people understood they were
ratifying in 1791 when they adopted the
bill of rights in the second amendment.
That is not the process of liquidation.
Liquidation applies to those parts of
the constitution that were invented
whole cloth by James Madison and the
founders. What is the commerce clause
maybe? Right? What are these different
things? You know what are these terms?
How did the Senate work? What are the
Senate rules? What is an inferior court?
What are the jurisdiction in the Supreme
Court? WHAT IS A CASE OR CONTROVERSY?
YOU KNOW, WHAT WHATEVER THESE OTHER
terms are in the Constitution, maybe
they were brand new at the time. It was
made up. And when Madison writes about
this, and this is what Madison writes,
he's talking about the new parts of the
Constitution THAT HAD NO HISTORICAL
BASIS. And when something is brand new
and has NO HISTORICAL BASIS, YEAH, maybe
you can engage in the doctrine of
liquidating or liquidation to understand
the meaning by virtue of how the
founding fathers actually practiced
under the new constitution for a period
of decades after it was enacted. But
that's not the second amendment which
again deals with a pre-existing right.
You look backwards for the second
amendment. Maybe you can look forward a
few decades with the other provisions of
the constitution that are brand new and
you go through the process of
liquidation. That is what Madison was
talking about. Here's what Madison says.
Check it out. As James Madison wrote, "A
regular course of a practice can
liquidate and settle the meaning of
disputed indeterminate terms and
phrases." So, Judge Pitman quotes that
language and then says, "Well, that
means I can go to the 19th century. I
can do all this other stuff." No. The
process of liquidation, but according to
James Madison, is the new stuff we made
up with this brand new constitution that
never existed in world history. If
there's some questions about it, then
the practice of the founders in the
first several decades can liquidate the
meeting and clarify what it means. For
example, when John Marshall decides
Marberry versus Madison about judicial
review, that's kind of an illustration,
something brand new out there um that
arguably you could argue there's some
liquidation going on there. But when
you're dealing with the Second
Amendment, you do not want liquidation.
And by the way, if you allow for
liquidation as a theory to be smuggled
into the Second Amendment land, I 100%
guarantee that the anti-gunners will use
this to narrow the scope of the
protections of the right to keep and
bear arms. So, if you support the Second
Amendment, you 100% should not be
supporting liquidation or Madison's
views of liquidation in this context
because IT'S SIMPLY OBJECTIVELY WRONG to
do it. And it's also terrible if you
respect the right to keep arms because
it's going to wind up biting you on the
dupa and narrowing the scope of our
protections. Bad, bad idea. All right,
so there you have it. I hope you enjoyed
my quick analysis of Judge Pitman's
decision in Zegan Fuss versus Martin
dealing with these three so-called
sensitive places down there in Texas. Uh
let me know if you disagree in the
comments below. Anyway, hope you did
enjoy it. Make sure you follow me over
there on X4box of Dire. Don't forget to
subscribe both the YouTube and the
Rumble and I'll talk to you again real
soon here at the Vorbox Diner.
>> Orders up. Table 2A.